is it true that your your daughter
tortures you your it is incredibly
insulting yes my daughter is who's 11
has turned into like this burn artist
but only focused on me right like we
were playing 20 questions recently and
she asked like is it animal or mineral
like the the first questions you asking
20 questions animal she goes okay is it
human it's like no it's not human and
she goes okay okay oh it's daddy that's
a burn yeah that's a pretty good pretty
decent burn wasted a question on yeah
yeah about winning a game as long as you
felt ballsy exactly she wasted two
questions just on the set up to to a
pretty decent burn she also the the
another time she I was going on a trip
and she as I was leaving she said daddy
um I put a note in your backpack but
don't don't read it until you're on the
plane okay and I was just like oh my god
my daughter like that's the stuff you
dream about when you have children
particularly daughter for whatever
reason I just always wanted that sort of
like love from her and so I get on the
plane and then I'm like oh my god this
this note going to my backpack and I
find it in the in the front pocket
there's this like post-it that's been
folded in half and opened it up and it
says you suck
[Applause]
not even artful it was devastating well
you'll get that framed and you'll have
it forever